former US Attorney Preet Bharara
successfully prosecuted several
high-profile cases during his time with
the Southern District of New York the
list includes Osama bin Laden's
son-in-law the attempted Times Square
bomber Faisal Shahzad and the notorious
Russian arms dealer Viktor Boothe
Barrera was fired by President Trump
after he refused to resign as US
attorney for the Southern District of
New York his new book is called doing
justice a prosecutor's thoughts on crime
punishment and the rule of law it draws
on his decades of legal experience to
shed light on how the country's justice
system works good morning Preet great to
have you at the table nice to be here
so as we wait for the Muller report
which may or may not come this week
there are a lot of people already
tempering expectations of what we can
expect out of it and say the greater
legal legal threat to the president
comes from the Southern District of New
York you agree I think so yes I'm still
reeling from the story about the
sextuplets yeah in nine minutes
nine in nine minutes never been from
that productive in my life but the
Southern District is very productive you
know the difference between the Southern
District of New York and especial
counsel's office is the special
counsel's office mission was
circumscribed by what rod Rosenstein the
acting Attorney General at the time for
purposes of this case said they could
look at which included Russian collusion
and things that are rows from that
investigation whereas this other
district folks that I write about a lot
in the book given my experience here for
seven and a half years they're not
circumscribed by anything they can look
at crime as they see fit they can bring
a case against anyone they think the
Justice the interest of Justice serve
they don't care how powerful you are
they don't care what party you're from
they don't care where your assets are
they're tough and aggressive independent
and so no matter what happens with the
Special Counsel investigation the
Southern District of New York which you
were formerly the US Attorney of
currently has at least four
investigations open that we know about
campaign conspiracy and the Trump
Organization inauguration funding
Trump's super PAC funding and foreign
lobbying is that a lot on one sort of
person in their organization yeah I mean
they can handle it they can they can
come and walk at the same time
I mean look they do hundreds of
investigations and there are lots and
lots of talented people there and some
of the best people that I've ever met
and one of the things I that I'm pleased
about in the book is letting people know
about some of the folks who are not
famous who you don't see on television
whose names you might not know but are
the unsung heroes in keeping New York
safe and keeping the country safe I mean
one of the things you write about in the
book too is that investigations are hard
yeah they are yeah it's not just connect
the dots and follow the money
explain a little bit more about that
yeah you can apparently not to keep
going back to this you can have stuck
sextuplets in nine minutes if you can't
you can't do an investigation that
quickly you never know where an
investigation might lead you know one of
the things that I think it's important
to remember is when you begin
investigating excuse me
when you begin an investigation you have
to keep an open mind you can't have a
thesis in advance and sometimes you go
down the path and you think you're gonna
find criminality and it turns out not to
be so and sometimes you're gonna go down
the path you think it's a long shot and
you end up being able to prove a case so
you know I think in this age of Trump
when people jump to conclusions and
people chant lock her up and lock him up
it's good to take a step back and to
think about what justice means how it's
done how its warded what fair-mindedness
means what due process is those lessons
have been a little bit lost I think in
the last couple of years yeah you point
out we need to get back to that you also
talked about in the book I was
fascinated by this that prosecutors
often fascinated and repulsed by mob
activity we've got a really interesting
story in the news right now where the
apparent boss of the Gambino family was
assassinated outside his home and
everybody thought that it was a mob hit
so when you look at that case what are
you thinking and talk about being
fascinated and repulsed by mob activity
yeah you know we were talking before the
show
Gail about you have to be interested in
the subject matter and lots of probably
my favorite movies are mob movies I
think and I and I wanted to be a mob
prosecutor and I was when I was a lion
assistant I thought when that
assassination happened like everyone
else the first first thought is it must
be a mob war yes when the reputed head
of the Gambino crime family is shot to
death outside of his home but then as I
also point in the book repeatedly over
and over again things are not always
what they seem
and sometimes you think that a person
committed the crime and that's where you
know all the leads point and that's what
common sense tells you that get you in a
lot of trouble they can be miscarriages
of justice and it looks like it again we
should remain with an open mind that
maybe it was it had something to do with
a love interest and had nothing to do
with mob warfare you say ask a lot of
questions there's no such thing as a
dumb question
is that a question
I happen to think that's I was surprised
to hear you say it though no it's very
true I think it's true if you're if
you're a new person in a job like our
rookie assistant US Attorney's that I
used to say to them a surprise question
in a case is worse than a suppressed
piece of evidence because the only way
you can get true knowledge about subject
matter and make sure that you understand
what you're saying
when you get information from someone
else is to ask questions not just smart
questions but basic questions you owned
this oh yeah sorry since we're just
running out of time
why are you skeptical that the Muller
investigation is coming to an end it may
be coming to an end but I keep seeing
conflicting pieces of evidence it's sort
of like the things are not what they
seem we jump to conclusions too quickly
so on the one hand
Andrew Weissman who is the top deputy is
leaving there are lots of people who are
reporting who I presume have decent
sources and are very smart who say it's
winding down but then on the other hand
you have Rick gates who's sentencing has
been postponed yet again the fifth time
for the fifth time in a letter submitted
on Friday which said that he's
continuing to cooperate in not one but
several investigations that makes it
seem like the work of the special
counsel is not done all right Preet
Bharara thank you so much AKA drama
queen according to your ten-year-old
daughter i love that part and you learn
about his son in his Rubik's cubes yeah
I think family's doing just as it goes
on sale tomorrow wherever you like to
buy your books